[Musique]
notre amour est il allé dans mon sous
sol
après les mauves en noir puis
jean-françois paris a été déployé en
bosnie à kaboul et à kandahar
c'est en afghanistan que sa vie de
soldat la bascule est d'allouer le 3
février
dans nuit des jo un avion qui apportait
à deux châteaux qui était décédé elle
était mon bâton camara 2006 revenu de
l'horreur où le quotidien se conjuguait
entre ses frères d'armes tombés au
combat et les images de femmes et
d'enfants mort sur le bord des routes
afghanes
jean-françois va connaître une véritable
descente aux enfers on parle ça touche
et agréé labo les amis qu'on a perdus
puis plongé deux amis se sont suicidés
par après les amis proches puis au
quotidien on se promène une forme cela
ma fierté ma raison me lever le matin
puis du jour au lendemain ça s'arrête
parce que j'étais plus apte à sauver mon
pays parce que j'ai un certain nombre
d'autres espèces en asie 4,5 ce moment
alors je me suis pas dit plus et puis
j'ai monté au deuxième étage à l'hôpital
à valcartier comme on dit là j'ai monté
l'escalier de la honte c'est quoi
l'escalier de laon à l'hôpital au
deuxième étage c'est tout ce qu'ils
pourraient puisque alogues ce qu'il ya
autour et sociales sacais faible 4
monte-escalier l'eau ces mots
puisqu'elle mercy fois avant de la
montée
après l'hôpital bilan non travaillées
une fois j'ai su que j'allais monter
malgré moi merci d'être là non
participants sont les trois sont arrivés
après presque dix ans à broyer du noir
jean-françois va faire la rencontre de
steve charbonneau marché l'ancien joueur
de football des alouettes de montréal
dirige depuis cinq ans la fondation des
sports adaptés un organisme qui utilise
le sport pour sortir les personnes à
mobilité réduite de leur isolement
soit les encourager bénévole depuis deux
ans jean-françois s'est trouvé une
nouvelle mission le problème est qu'elle
lui si on n'était pas là ça lui permet
de sortir de chez eux fait que
aujourd'hui ch
je peux dire que ça alors sauvé ma vie
aujourd'hui
j'entrevois soit d'un autre même après
leur mort il ya d'autres choses qu'avant
d'être chaude au gt1 et moyens avec un
car l'armée l'a fait que je suis devenu
comme ça ne faisait pas grand mérite de
reprendre ce thème et j'ai trouvé ma
boîte avant de se quitter
jean françois paré voulait absolument
lancer ce message m il ya d'autres
choses après sortez de chez vous appelez
un ami
d'après moi ils vont vous donner mon
numéro a privé par exemple puis je vous
dis quoi après vous savez dix sorties
lors nous et puis ça m'a pris quand même
9 8 à découvrir
on a toutes les ressources pour
consulter on a tout ce qu'on a besoin
monter lorsque les larves relais
montémont 6 pieds 4 % à lille j'allais
monter
faut-il parce que je vous aime plus
faibles
ici robert frosi radio-canada au moins
un enfant